welcome back the Epicurean charitable
Foundation is now taking scholarship
applications here to tell us more is
Christopher Alfieri with the Epicurean
charitable foundation and this is Layla
Alvarez a UNLV Student and also a
scholarship recipient welcome you guys
thank you thank you so much it's great
to have you on the show Christopher
let's start with you tell everyone more
about the foundation absolutely so we
are a food and beverage Foundation
fluoride scholarship in order to apply
for the for the scholarship you need to
have a 3.0 GPA you need to be in the
hospitality field which is hotel
management event planning anything
really under that umbrella that will
Encompass Hospitality which is a huge
variety here in this town and you have
to come from a family income of seventy
thousand dollars or less and we're
talking about going to UNLV correct who
can apply for this who's eligible any
Clark County senior in high school and
this year we are also doing UNLV
freshmen and sophomores as well oh so
freshman's watching right now and
they're like hey I didn't hear about
this program I'm already a year in they
can still jump on they can absolutely
jump on board Layla what was it like
when when you found out that you were
getting the scholarship what did that
feel like oh God I still remember the
feeling as if it was yesterday I feel
like that feeling will still stick with
me
um it was Unreal it was emotional to say
the least but I was very happy to be
awarded this scholarship because of
course it'll put me into my stepping
stool to get into my career absolutely
what a great school what a great program
this is going to launch your career and
you have some other people helping you
along the way there's a mentorship
program involved tell us more about this
so yes each year you do receive a mentor
this Mentor could either be in food and
beverage Hotel operations or event
management which is my current mentor
and she is currently the vice president
of event management over at MGM so
having that and wanting to be in events
definitely pushes you towards you know
meeting new people gaining those
experiences so having a guide not only
in your college life but getting ahead
in your professional life is also a plus
being in the scholarship it's networking
is what it is too you're meeting these
people in town these high-level
Executives if someone wants to get
involved with that mentorship program
are you guys looking for more mentors so
uh typically in order to be a board
member uh we kind of have to vet you or
you have to be referred to us from our
existing board members you have to have
a certain position in the hospitality
Community
um really all just depends but we are
always on the lookout now Leila what's
your plan after graduation you told me
you're graduating in 2024 what's your
plan after graduation because that's
that's going to sneak up on you real
fast next thing you know you're walking
down that aisle getting your diploma I
can't believe it feels like last year I
was just a freshman but yeah going into
my third year right now of course
getting through school and of course
meeting new people so right now I
definitely want to be in the event
industry and events you know special
events conferences meetings Expos I've
always been drawn to I love it so I've
wanted to get my foot in the door for
events and you're doing that real quick
Christopher as we wrap it up what's the
website for people to apply uh so they
can either go to pef.org which is public
Education Foundation or you you can go
to our personal website which is
ecflv.org awesome thank you so much you
too so coming up this is a December to
remember we're talking to the Las Vegas